hey Leute heute stelle ich euch den
neuen Minecraft Snapshot 12 w15a vor und
zwar hat sich moang da ein kleines
Späßchen erlaubt und zwar da wo bei
denen auf der Website moyang.com ist das
glaube ich da stehen sonst mal die
kompletten Updates und Informationen und
diesmal hat sich moyang gedacht ach komm
verarschen wir doch die User mal
schreiben wir da einfach mal zensiert
hin also zensort im englischen natürlich
weil die da schwedisch sind und die
hauptsächlichen Spieler Englisch sind
und blabla etc und so weiter jedenfalls
standen da überhaupt keine Informationen
was für
Updates bzw was für Neuerungen hier drin
enthalten sind das heißt man muss das
sich alles selbst zusammenuchen eine
Sache habe ich selbst herausgefunden
beim Rest habe ich mich dann auf andere
Quellen und andere Videos bezogen und
zwar fangen wir mal ganz einfach an ich
habe mir so ein kleinen Zettel
vorbereitet und zwar Boote hier ihr seht
das zack zack hier gehen mal weg
hieralala so Hop also hier kommen jetzt
immer Boote aus Dispensern raus wenn man
da auf den Schalter drückt und
so so also da kommen Bote raus aus den
Dispensern und das Gleiche kann man auch
bei Minecarts machen das heißt die kommt
z.B jetzt Minecart mit einem Furness
raus so dann kommt h z.B in Minecart ein
ganz normales raus und hier kann ups
jetzt sit sich hier drin und hier kann
auch ein man können mal bitte danke so
meincart mit der Kiste kann da auch
rauskommen also einfach hier meinecarts
reintun auf dem Butten drücken und dann
kommen die da raus ist eigentlich
relativ cool wenn ihr irgendwie weiß ich
nicht in der Mine seid einfach Schalter
drücken Items re werfen irgendwas
müsstet ihr euch was einfallen lassen
und die fahren hier noch ihre Runden na
ja wir kümmenn uns mal um die nächsten
Sachen also es gab bei too many items
relativ viele neue Neuigkeiten und zwar
drücke ich mal einfach oben to many
items hier oben könnt wir jetzt auf den
Schwierigkeitsgrad einfach normal schwer
friedlich einfach normal schwer einfach
die ganze Zeit umstellen müsst jetzt
nicht mehr rausgehen eigentlich könnt
ihr mittlerweile alles hier to many
items machen mit Regen ein aus Creative
Mode Sonne Sonnenuntergang Nacht und so
weiter alles mögliche kann man jetzt
damit machen und was ihr hier seht die
gibt es bisher nur in too many items
übelst viele neue Pilzsorten ihr seht
das hier das ist echt richtig heftig
aber mit denen die sind zurzeit noch ein
bisschen komisch also ihr seht dass ich
platziere die aber hier ist irgendwie
nicht diese Wand dieses Dingens drum
dieses rote was da eigentlich sein
sollte oder hier funktioniert gerade
alles noch nicht so gut ich weiß nicht
woran es liegt aber na ja ist halt alles
ein bisschen bisschen pervers hier
gerade was ich gebaut habe na ja egal so
also das ist halt noch so ein bisschen
Buggy damit so die nächste Sache ist ich
gebe mir mal einfach kurz hier wo haben
wir es denn wo haben wir es denn hier
das hier könnte ich ja mal eben das hier
das hier und das hier dann mache ich
mich mal eben in den Survival Mode und
zwar wenn ich jetzt hier shift drücke
dann setzt er die Sachen sofort auf also
dieses komplette mit dem shift drücken
WD noch mal perfektioniert finde ich auf
jeden Fall geil weil früher muss man
sich die ganzen Sachen da mal hinziehen
mittlerweile einfach mit Shift perfekt
und das gleiche ist auch wieder drauf
klicken ist es wieder weg und so weiter
also ist ganz geh ganz cool was was die
da bisher alles dazugefügt haben also
bisher so dann wenn ich jetzt z.B so ein
spawck habe das ist jetzt von dem Huhn
glaube ich ja von dem Huhn ich setze das
irgendwo hin dann kommen jetzt kleine
Tiere ich kann auch mal eben wieder in
den Creative Mode gehen Moment so so so
Tralala was haben wir denn hier sonst
noch so wir haben hier ein Schaf z.B
drück ich hier mit auf den Boden dann
kommt ein babyschaf also da kommen jetzt
wirklich nur noch babytiere raus und
nicht mehr diese großen Tiere und was
auch ganz cool ist ich gehe mal eben
hier in mein kleines Gehege rein wenn
ich die mittlere Maustaste im Creative
Mode drücke bekomme ich hier von ein SP
und wenn ich hier die mittlere mausasse
drücke bekomme ich halt davon eins dann
bekomme ich hier von z.B so und wenn ich
dann z.B hier die mittlere Maustaste
drauf drücke aber ich habe hier vor
schon eins im Inventar dann springe ich
halt automatisch wieder dahin was auch
ganz cool ist da muss man z.B nicht wenn
man ein Tier sieht und das selbst Spen
will lassen will die ganze Zeit in dem
ach die fressen mir das Gras Weg in den
Einstellungen suchen sondern können
einfach mit der mittleren Maustaste da
drauf drücken so sehr schön egal so und
außerdem was ziemlich kacke ist finde
ich ich bin im Creative Mode zieh mir
z.B hier ein paar Items raus so möchte
nun z.B früher ging das so wenn ich so
ein Dingens hier drauf tue und irgendwo
hinklicke verschwindet das und
mittlerweile kriegt man dann das
gunpowder hier kriegt man die das hier
ich weiß nicht ob das ein Bug ist aber
man kann die Sache nur noch hier unten
löschen das heißt man muss die hier
unten reinziehen damit das funktioniert
finde ich ein bisschen blöd früher was
so dass wenn ich hier drauf klicke z.B
wenn ich jetzt das dieses Qi hier drauf
klicke kriege ich davon mehr aber wenn
ich das auf irgendein anderes Item drauf
ziehe dann verschwindet das halt und das
lös funktioniert halt nicht mehr so gut
das waren jetzt auch schon eigentlich
die die groben Änderung also die näheren
genauere Änderung findet ihr noch in der
Beschreibung bzw allgemein die Website
mit dem Späßchen was S sich da erlaubt
haben h crazy na ja egal so nein neinin
nein das wollte ichar nicht egal es gibt
noch ein paar sonstige Änderungen und
zwar ihr könnt mit diesem Update nun
auch auf ältere Server gehen also von
der
1.2.5 also mit diesem 12W 15A könnt ihr
auch auf Elter Server gehen und dieses
shift klicken funktioniert und auch mit
brauchständen das heißt wenn ihr
irgendwie eine Flasche in der Hand habt
und bei einem brauchstand dann auf shift
drückt dann packt er die da automatisch
rein na ja also das waren die Änderungen
ihr findet noch mal die ganzen
Änderungen die ich hier vorgestellt habe
die Website und vielleicht noch ein paar
Änderung die ich dann nachher hinzufügen
werde in der Beschreibung ich stell mich
auf das Ding was ich gebaut habe und
dann würde ich sagen Lags sehen wir uns
beim nächsten Video ciao